voici trois informations insolites sur
le T-Rex 1 son nom complet le
Tyrannosaurus rex signifie le roi des
lézards tyran Tyrano pour tyran sorus
qui signifie lézard en grec et Rex le
roi en latin ce nom n'a pas été choisi
au hasard puisque ce redoutable
carnivore qui mesurait plus de 10 m
dévorait tout ce qui lui tombait sous
les griffes 2 le gigantesque T-Rex avait
un cerveau de la taille de celui d'un
oiseau mais une grande partie de ce
minuscule organe était consacré à la
transmission d'information liée aux
odeurs et à leur traitement on pense que
ce géant possédait des capacités
olfactives exceptionnelles équivalentes
à celles d'un chat ce qui lui permettait
de repérer ses proies de très long 3
dans l'imaginaire collectif le T-Rex est
un chasseur solitaire mais la découverte
en Amérique du Nord de fossiles de
plusieurs individus sur un même site
laisse supposer que ce dinosaure vivait
en réalité en meut